that is the damaged Chernobyl nuclear
reactor in 1986 after the accident it
was encased in the sarcophagus that you
can see now
but it's weathering and cracking and
needs to be replaced so they're building
a new confinement structure over here
they can't build it above the old
sarcophagus because the levels of
radiation are still too high so they'll
have to slide the whole structure across
it'll cost billions of dollars and this
structure will last a hundred years
and that is only a temporary solution
because the half-life of uranium-238 is
four and a half billion years
it's the same as the lifetime of the
Earth
so in five billion years when all life
has ceased on this planet
and the Sun is engulfing the Earth
only half of the uranium which is still
in that sarcophagus will have decayed
away